What happened to the Seer?
If he's gone, we
need to find him.
And if somebody has tried to
kill him, we need to know who
and why.
I know.
The Lord came
to me last night.
He showed me a vision.
A vision of Hell
and the damned that
must endure its fires for all
eternity, and I was afraid.
I must renounce our love.
You know something?
Your soul, whatever
that is, meant
more to you than I ever could.
I don't think you
ever did love me.
My lord Canahad.
You are arrested for treason.
Were you part of a conspiracy
to overthrow my son Alfred?
[crying]
No.
I need to know.
And I will know.
Tell us the weight you
need in gold and silver
to go and leave Wessex.
Come back tomorrow
and I will tell
you and your Christian
friends what you must pay.
No one has come.
Of course not.
They're not going to come.
They were not
really negotiating.
While we have
been waiting here,
they have moved their entire
army around our flanks
and are now almost
certainly positioned
in the very place
they had already
chosen for the battleground.
King Harald.
Why is the ground burned?
To battle!
For Christ, for Wessex,
and for England!
[shouting]
[music playing]
The king lives!
Long live the king.
[grunting]
Lagertha!
When King Harald urged his
devils to run from the field,
I knew then that the day and
the battle had belonged to us!
[crowd cheering]
The conspiracy against you.
Those who wish to
overthrow and kill you.
I know their names.
Aethelred is their leader.
I think I have found her.
This is not her.
My mother always carried
Thor's hammer around her waist.
I don't think we are
going to find her.
Magnus, son of Ragnar.
What is to become of us now?
I have faith that
we shall prevail.
Our gods will ultimately triumph
over the Christian god, who's
a usurper, who has no meaning--
who's not real.
And one day not so far
away, the name Jesus Christ
will be utterly forgotten.
[chuckles]
[sighs]